- (audience clapping)
Let's hit one last story
sure to warm your heart.
This is What I'm Liking.
(theme music)
(audience cheering)
- Last month I met an
awesome 8-year-old girl
named Darcey, who's
going through some med,
some serious medical challenges.
She was especially eager to
tell me about her music video
that she made, which I got
to see, which was awesome.
Not just because she'd made a video,
but rather because of the
four backup dancers in it,
they're actually Darcey's
nurses and met her
at university hospital in San Antonio.
Darcey wanted me to give
them a Texas size shout out
for being her friend and helping her out.
So we have these amazing
women on the line right now
watching on Fox 29, San Antonio 4 p.m.
(audience cheering)
Let's say hello to Priscilla,
Erin, Alissa and Becky!
(audience cheering)
Hi ladies! (clapping)
- [Nurses] Hi!
- First of all, I adore
Darcey, her whole family.
They were all there, I kind
of got to see everybody.
Oh my gosh. What a beautiful little girl.
She's so great.
- She's amazing. Yes.
We met her a little over a year ago
when she started her
treatment here with us.
And I don't know how
you can know Darcey and
not fall in love with her.
She's just a sweetheart.
She's always in a charming mood.
She's just an incredible person.
And even on her worst days,
her hardest days of treatment,
she's always smiling and in a happy mood,
we're just so fortunate to know her.
And she's just an
inspiration to all of us here
and everyone who is fortunate
enough to know her as well.
- Yes, she has got such a beautiful smile.
And I got to know like,
how did the music video come together?
She asked you all to be in it?
- Yes. So when she asks us
to be a part of the video,
we just knew that we had to
make it extra special for her.
I've been a pediatric nurse
since before I had children
of my own. They are now
four and two years old.
And when I see the challenges
that Darcey is facing,
I just can't help, but
think of them as well.
So whenever she asks us to
be a part of this video,
we try to make it extra special.
So we actually had these shirts made
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- and we surprised Darcey
and her mom with one as well.
(audience clapping)
So her mom was actually the
one who recorded the video,
and when she played it back
to us, we were just so amazed.
I mean, you can see
her passion for dancing
and for singing with
all of her expressions
and her dance moves and
it just meant the world
to the four of us to see her so happy.
And that was our goal
just to make her happy.
And I think we achieved it
and we were just so honored
to have been a part of this.
- Well it's so special, y'all.
(audience clapping)
It's such a scary time
I can only imagine for
not only the parents, I know
y'all have some kids too,
like just for her to
be in that, that space,
it's such a hard space
to, for anyone to be in,
let alone a child and to do this for her,
it's such a beautiful thing, so
I wanted to bring you on
here, bring on the show
because I know she loves y'all so much.
And I didn't get a chance
to say hi to y'all,
when I talked to Darcey,
so thank y'all so much.
It's so cool.
(clapping)
Y'all did with her.
And also thank you so much for
all you're doing for everybody right now.
You know, it's an incredibly
hard couple of years
that we've all experienced,
so thank you so much
for being there for us at,
you know, at your hospital
and taking care of people.
We really, really appreciate you.
Thank you so much for that.
(audience clapping)
And thank you! I'm liking
your post right now!
(audience cheering)
And I know that Darcey is super grateful
for all you do for her and
all your other patients.
And she's not the only one,
our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2, the go-to pin,
other Kelly Clarkson Show once to honor,
ultimate overachievers, just like you.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
That's $250 each! Just cause you're cool!
(audience cheering)
- [Nurses] Thank you!
- [Kelly] Thank you ladies!
(clapping)
Have a blessed day y'all!
Thank you for joining us!